to say one of the issues hovering over
the draft that we've kind of forgotten
about i mean it's been the biggest story
in the nfl for six weeks now as the
draft approaches it's been crickets as
it relates to sean watson and let me
preface all this by saying as usual i
don't know a damn thing but i will say
this
based upon studying this case very
carefully following every development
throwing the 18 years i practiced law
under the fire to help understand what's
occurring when you have such a high
profile and public piece of litigation
as we've seen with desean watson 22
plaintiffs tony busby who represents all
22 plaintiffs actively on social media
multiple press conferences
and you've got rusty hardin high profile
lawyer who represents desean watson and
he's responded with statements in a
press conference and and it just did
they have been at each other's throats
and then since last friday when they
were in court making some serious
accusations of destruction of evidence
by the parties involved six days later
chris
there hadn't been a damn thing said
tweeted instagrammed nothing it's been
silent why my based on everything well
well there's only one explanation
and the explanation is
that the lawyers realize there's a
window of opportunity to settle these
cases
because from deshaun watson's
perspective
what he's willing to compensate the
alleged victims for the amount that he's
willing to pay and it boils down to and
i know it seems odd to people who aren't
familiar with the legal system it
basically is haggling over the price of
a used car when the time comes to work
out a case the numbers take over
you set aside what's right and wrong you
set aside what happened you turn it into
something that will be palatable in the
form of justice for the individual who
has a grievance against the defendant
i think
that they're trying to work something
out this is the time to do it it's got
no more value to sean watson than right
now because if we hear at some point
today
that a preliminary settlement has been
reached between deshaun watson and the
22 individuals or they not even not even
preliminary it's done paperwork signed
sealed and delivered it's over criminal
investigation's over he's free and clear
from a legal standpoint no commissioner
exemplifies to worry about
if that happens today
he's in play to get traded during the
draft i i i don't doubt that you know
mike it goes back again you know i
i was surprised remember about two weeks
ago when i told you i just
some of the things i was kind of hearing
from teams where
people were still kind of keeping this
alive a little bit like they thought
this was going to get resolved and you
know yeah listen there was some
insensitive takes there a little bit
from what i heard from people around the
nfl and all that but
he's he's unless it's like something
absolutely egregiously horrible happens
or something like that to where it's
just like
wow there's great evidence here and you
know watson is every bit the jerk we
think or thought he was in this whole
process or whatever and i'm not trying
to judge i'm just giving it for instance
you know
um
i i think he's too damn talented he's
too good so if they find a deal and they
get this done
and now there's a you know a financial
agreement done with all the the
plaintiffs and everything like that
there's gonna still be a lot of interest
in this guy he's one of the five ten
best players in the league there's no
doubt about that it's just about we're
dwindling away with the teams that
possibly can make a a play for him here
as we we go through the draft
one of the points that was made last
week by rusty harden the lawyer for
desean watson when the official
paperwork was filed in response to these
22 lawsuits and this was not a document
that was crafted for the benefit of the
courts it was a document that got filed
with the courts but was crafted for the
benefit of the media i believe to help
us better understand their position
there's only a small handful of
individuals who claim that there was any
type of forcible misconduct by desean
watson i believe a settlement number one
would likely entail a greater payment
for those persons and number two it
would entail some sort of a retraction
by them of the allegation of forcible
misconduct i think that's a critical
ingredient to getting deshaun watson to
a place where he is employable by
another nfl team right and won't be
facing a full season suspension by the
league because that's the other side of
it chris yes even though the
commissioner exempt list goes away which
is paid leave it likely undoubtedly goes
away because there's no there's no
reason to wait and see what happens
there's nothing further to happen the
cases are over it's done it's finito as
pat shurmur said a couple of years ago
but
he's still going to get suspended i
believe when you look at what happened
with ben roethlisberger in 2010 yep
where there were two
claims one was a lawsuit one never even
became a lawsuit he wasn't prosecuted he
wasn't civilly charged may have been a
settlement two incidents and when you
look at the language of the letter from
the commissioner ben roethlisberger it's
very easy to take lines and reasoning
from that letter and apply it to sean
watson given this whole
at least 40
people who he was getting massages from
and the admission by rusty hardin of
some consensual activity during some of
these massages i think that's enough for
the league to impose a suspension the
question is what's it going to be two
four eight who knows
but
i think that that is more palatable for
a team that would trade for him yeah
than this this
this
uncertainty right what what what's how
long he's going to go play is it two
years we're gonna have to pay him more
than 45 million over the next two years
while he's on the commissioner exempt
list so
these get cleared away
and the clock's ticking loudly
uh i i can't remember the very profound
thing you said about time before the
program i should remember particularly
was
time keeps ticking
time keeps ticking toward the draft and
if they're going to do it it's got to
happen and it doesn't happen have to
happen before the draft begins
but
i think at some point this weekend we
need to hear
that it's happened and i think the teams
that would be interested and we're going
to pivot to that now they need to be
clued in behind the scenes
yeah definitely in that direction so
they need to be ready to make their move
if and when this deal's done that that's
that's to me like the big thing is
they're like you know let's
like i don't think we're surprised by
any of the teams we heard that are
interested right the dolphins the jets
the patriots the broncos washington
chicago the panthers the 49ers are all
the teams we thought and talked about
and discussed you know back when before
deshaun watson and all these allegations
became about so all the a lot of those
teams more than half of them it's gone
it's fallen by the wayside you know the
i think the jets conversation is over
the denver conversation i believe is
over now
uh the carolina and the 49er
conversation is over so that leaves it
down to i guess new england can still be
in this conversation
but
miami washington and chicago and yeah i
mean i think what jumps out to me is
like we know miami's not in the draft
for a quarterback or at least we think
so unless that's something crazy that
happens tonight but washington and the
bears might be and yeah this weekend
could dictate
their ability to make a move for watson
if he did become available next week or
anything like that so that's where you
know you're right that investigative
information having some firsthand
knowledge of what's really going on down
there could help some of those teams if
they're still got him on their radar
even though miami has never been in
serious play for a quarterback in this
draft and the moment they traded from
three to twelve even though they
swung back to six and are in position to
catch one of these guys as they fall and
i can't rule out anything at this point
but they've always been linked loosely
to watson regardless of what they're
thinking about in in the draft because
deshawn watson to otago by low i mean
it's a no-brainer to sean watson we
instantly knew
deshaun watson in 2017 the minute he got
on the field the guy's special franchise
quarterbacks manifest themselves very
quickly and very obviously the moment
that they're out there playing against
nfl caliber competition chris i
look at this list of teams yeah that you
mentioned the only two that i think are
definitely out are the jets and the
49ers given their plans to take their
future franchise quarterbacks tonight at
two and three respectively i think
everybody else is in play i think the
panthers are in play you're right they i
think they're in pain they are they
could trade sam donald to the texans and
the texans that you're right they could
do that you're right so i'm i was wrong
about originally saying that i i agree
you know i'm glad you brought it up
because i was really sitting here going
wait the broncos could trade drew lock
and teddy bridgewater to the texans too
for deshaun watson so they're they're
not out of it i was wrong to say that
right off the bat that was kind of me
being caught by the the things that have
gone on here in recent history so you're
right i i think you can keep everybody
alive except for the jets and the 49ers
at this point
drew luck's best moment by far
happiest houston against the texans with
jack easter b and cal mcnair there to
witness it in the 2019 season so uh
affordable back end of a rookie contract
and uh you throw him into that trade and
you you help
bolster the quarterback position in
houston as part of that deal and the
more teams they can get interested you
know for a while we're thinking well if
the texans are going to get anything
it's going to be next to nothing they
could swing this thing back and and get
a decent return if there are you know
two three four teams that are clamoring
to try to get him two other teams i want
to mention right because i i reported a
couple weeks ago the eagles are a team
that will be
and
in it you know maybe they weren't
before the legal issues but now that
they see an opportunity to possibly buy
low they will be in it now maybe the
price goes up quickly and they're out
but i think they are a team to monitor
and
what about the raiders i you think
deshawn watson going to turn up his nose
at the chance to now i don't know if the
texans want derek carr after what
happened with david carr but
do you really think john gruden wouldn't
explore the possibility of getting to
sean watson
uh
i mean no he's gonna he's gonna take a
look i would think you know of course
watson's special like you know like
we've talked about so they're gonna look
but
i i don't i don't think the raiders are
gonna get
get interested in that to to a point to
where they're gonna be a major player i
don't i think derek carr played too well
last year and i'll go back to like what
i said back at the time too a little bit
he's finally wired his robot what i mean
that with gruden and carr and they got a
lot of other things they got to deal
with on their football team i mean we've
we spent some time on it over the last
two weeks i mean
this is a big draft for them
they got major holes you know it's it's
going into year four with gruden and
there's still holes on the roster here
so that to me would be also the other
reason i think you know stan pat with
what you got he's trying to build
something watson's intriguing but i
don't know if i would do it if i'm the
raiders i wouldn't is what i'm saying
yeah um but just be be advised
this is one of those potential lightning
bolts that
that can come either out of the blue and
you have no idea it may happen or
when it happens you're going to say hey
those two idiots today were talking
about it and look here here here it
comes and now
which would instantly become the biggest
story of the draft desean watson
back in play yeah cases resolved traded
to a new team so keep that on your radar
screen as tonight approaches we're gonna
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports